okay well that's the title and the talk
will pretty much follow that title
doesn't always sometimes they just
organically grow with this one wheel as
Ian mentioned herbs it's on my mind the
moment and it has informed some of this
talk short while ago I decided that I
wanted to become a specialist because
now unappreciated generalists it's
terrible most generous are now actually
better specialists in any random field
than the specialists but anyway
specialists eventually become gurus and
then you just have to turn up and you
get paid in that it's pretty cool right
so I'm I sort of part of the guru that
may I decided to focus on data
visualizations it was an interest of
mine and I gave a few talks I gave it to
a PI that the last year which I think it
was part of the reason why right he
contacted me and as a result of that
kind of a book fell out so I I would
like to thank the PI data organizing
committee and Kirsten as well in equal
measure because writing the book is
really kind of hard I got my cover I was
really shuffler this apparently I really
don't let you choose your animal they
have a Kabbalistic thing they will get
together and decide but if you make a
special plea you can get the animal
choice I used to be the best
bumblebee trainer on earth so I wanted
sort of bumblebees of a sort or at least
bees and I made a hand wavy thing about
bees turning pollen into honey which is
a bit like turning data into a data
visualization it's a transformative and
I kind of wrote that on a scrap paper
and posted it off and I got my cover so
there you go that was cool right editors
are really good they ask you kind of
questions such as why you write in this
book that got me stumped for a while but
they talk about pain points so
what's the pain point was what am i
trying to address with this for me it
was I've been building gooeys for years
I was in sign of science research
scientist and in Python with our we
throw them qtw like spice and how all
this stuff with all these lovely gooeys
out there I think you ever see them
because they the distribution is a
problem they're just lying there the
dead and this is huge pressure towards
database on the web there's good reason
for the libraries are there in the
language is now very powerful
unfortunately Python isn't on the web
it's never gonna be on this is a web
browser smoking a web browser that's the
problem and so how do i during this date
of his party
this is suggestive to me it's begging a
question you have to accommodate
javascript if you're going to do data
visualization on the way which is
basically where you want it if you want
to distribute your data data there's to
every device on the planet
pretty much then javascript is what
you're gonna have to deal with so making
javascript play friendly with your
thanks your choice which is of course
Python because the data processing stack
is so brilliant this general-purpose
library there's nothing comparable etc
that's there's the question so what's
the problem here I think this is very
having spoken to a few people
I decided actually are some other
opinions rather than just relying on and
I got this sense that there's this thing
called web dev which is this horrible
gunk that stands between Faceman and
JavaScript is programming because Joseph
just program and we're programmers right
so this is horrible gunk and it's called
wait and it is how I used to do it back
in the day for a bit and when I first
started it was horrible the HTML was
boilerplate peril and even though this
is too lighter so you talk to web
developers and they've got gulps and
grunts all this crap and sass and you
get this feeling there's this huge kind
of stuff let your they eat your way
through it's not true you can do st. you
this you can program spend 95% of the
time programming in Python or JavaScript
which as I said is actually quite a nice
language and the only thing you need is
a little bridge between them
kind of permeable membrane rather than a
huge big chunk and you pass Jason
through that and at that point you're in
a programming context use programming
and eventually you kind of seamless
because the languages aren't that
different
there's some syntactical differences but
they're not profound so this is the
proposition proposition is that you can
take a small html5 skeleton little CSS
JavaScript is your data format a restful
api biking can roll these in a few lines
as I'll show you and then you're just
programming you're just creating data
generations in this case it could be
anything else could be very interesting
other things but in this case you can
call it one page app which essentially
means it's a folder you can take it you
can drop it in there in the website and
it'll just work so what do we mean by
weight visualizations anyway this is a
completely made-up graph but I think
there is an axis of exploration
presentation and I think the most many
of us have gone beyond various points in
this kind of graph but at the bottom for
Maya this is this this is the dark
secretive data vis that we all do when
we interact with - notebook was
something we're trying to find something
we don't intend to share it we don't
intend to - to distribute it and at the
old speaker old-school static is which
is essentially what visualization the
web has been up to now which is just
replacing newsprint with pixels sort of
this you know it's not clickable it's
not interactive but now with lobbies id3
the power is there to make these web
visitors completely dynamic interactive
exploratory and we can tie it to start
to take data vis the static and the web
is into the exploratory mode so I think
all the fun is in the middle the middle
is where you say look I've got the
toriel content I'm going to give you
some facets and basically impressions is
data but I can't into it what you want
exactly I'd like you explore you know I
hope to make that clear in a minute what
I mean by that I thought for this talk I
should code in the original
visualization and it was inspired by his
Andrew Clegg gave a very good PI data
talk on data vis and here it is I'm very
proud of it because I've arranged these
numbers in such a way
but they're very easy to read and digest
you can see the patterns in them I mean
sorry this was kind of a starting point
right difficult to make sense of of that
so I just thought hey if I order them in
columns that's amazing right
so I transform the data into something
that is if you look at it long enough
he'll probably work it out but some
people would say that that is a better
way to represent those numbers right I
mean I though I think the jury's out but
so so what saw was about overly it's
it's lovely it's hypnotic
that's what oh man what am I suggesting
what so everything it's about
transformation though the visit is about
transformation is about taking this
abstract data which has no shape or
structure and turn it into something
that gets into our primary visual cortex
because that's where human beings like
to play now I did that I want to make
the point I had that idea as a gimmick
okay so sketch as soon as I thought it
taught of it I was programming and it
was done within 45 minutes knocks I mean
great genius because my claw stuck
through the d3 with will do much more
elegant code but because when you start
using d3 which is an amazing library you
start to the point where that gap
between thinking something and doing it
becomes very narrow and I also want to
show the the web they've overhead for
this this is the index.html involved
that is all of the web dev shim if you
like that's it this is a valid index
this is a valid html5 page this has got
all the CSS involved in that amazing
visualization it's got little tags for
the control buttons and the charts got
the skeleton and everything else is just
programming which is empowering right
because you couldn't do that we have low
or any of that stuff you can only do
that when you get in a program you've
got a rich library that's incredibly
well designed using what's the grammar
graphics which is kind of basis of it
that's just code
his javascript not Python I'm afraid to
say but I'm not for insert because it's
JavaScript actually much nicer than you
might have heard and it gets better and
better this is a PA this family like a
shout of 4 D 3 D 3 sisters astonishingly
good live it's based on whether it looks
Instagram or graphics which ggplot2 is
based on that's the AIA library that all
Python this isn't terribly terribly end
yourself with good cause there's a
reason why they're both very famous and
they both work well they're implementing
this very profound above the theoretical
core is very strong and I just say might
boss that the prayer d3 code Z and
JavaScript when it was called protists
that was when JavaScript was a toy
language and so it was an amazingly kind
of insightful thing prescient rather the
thing about it is it's not a charting
like everybody in my herd you can use it
to build charting libraries but it
starts to just new forms of dative I
think we're on the cusp of new ways of
visualizing data bar charts actually got
two more for many things but there's so
many more things out there so this is
the data this tool chain which is the
base of the book I thought in it is
transformative vain how do we take a I
wanted to transform a Wikipedia page the
Nobel Prize page was just a lower list
of names into a modern into the modern
visualization and I want you to do that
in order to use all the libraries that
Python has my hand we've got sprayed
Peter scraping pandas for cleaning
exploration we've got flasks to deliver
and it's all done with Jason out of out
of HTML and they eventually transforms
into this library so it's great piece
great peers I need a dirty data so
scraping is great because it usually
produces reliably dirty data because
you're scraping human produced data from
human consumption so it's usually fairly
fairly yeah unclean
plus scrape isn't an amazingly powerful
library once you start using a there's
some we the sense of power is as long as
you press the button then it just drags
down at least a few want data training
sets if you want sets of photos so train
just in the training level it's it's
fantastic use but it's very well-written
and very powerful
and when you're used to it you get much
much quicker it employs things so you
scrape it you basically you just use
Chrome Explorer or anything you liked to
get the the tag the XPath over the
elements your interest this is Nobel
prize-winning photographs and little bio
that I wanted to use for my
digitalization so I tagged I if I work
out their structure within the HTML and
then I write a spider it's great to use
this this idea of spiders it's made them
quite easy to write that's most of the
code it's got this concept of pipelines
so afterward you have a post-processing
for images and and multimedia and
obviously covered in the book but it's
quite yeah after a while you get better
a it becomes quite easy to write them
and it does everything you need to do it
does throttling it does all the sensible
stuff anonymizing if you tried this by
hand with beautiful suit you'll probably
end up getting your eyes P banned and
your neighbor's IP and maybe your towns
ISP so it's it's sensible when you're
scraping to be quite cautious there
after scraping you get a nice array of
JSON objects but it's probably dirty and
you want to identify remove the
anomalies duplicates missing fields
formatting errors etc and just where
pandas comes in this is the cleaning
phase
pass is lovely as I'm sure many of you
aware I will use it the easier it
becomes to just deal with your data to
just in this case cleaning you load your
data or anything load it in from a
database I'm loading for a file it's got
lots of different options here I read in
my JSON data it's straight out of the
the scrapy cleaning as you can see it's
an array of objects which describe all
the Nobel Prize winners a few thousand
on them I just do a little info on that
data frame already I can see I'm missing
some gender fields there's a place of
death is
not all their describe you just do it
describing their frame a whole lot of
pretty interesting information drops out
you've got just here in this one thing
you can see we've got duplicates just
annual coming here name we have two of
him
what's going on there that's gonna have
to be addressed we have missing fields
many of them you can also see things
like how many countries 59 unique
countries no have won the Nobel Prize
and various other various other just
things drop out and it's very very
simple different little test
there were duplicates and these Jupiter
because this was a potential
international incident because they were
they were in outfits Lordan so you know
you remove them normally and you will
tend to favor countries with alpha with
letters in the alphabet lower down the
order so you just randomly permute
missing fields I just find which
categories and now you can see here Alex
peril is miss named he did when he won
the it's medicine physiology not
medicine so find that this is what
happens when human beings enter data
this is date of death if we have so the
date of death of Johannes and Eden van
der Valles is Stephen Vick court fake it
makes perfect sense
pants makes working with dates really
easy and he parties dated pretty
robustly
this is a few lines here we try and pass
the date so anything that fails we just
throw it out you can see it's really
easy way to find if your data is mister
categorizes the syntax is wrong in this
case obviously some of these date
formats year year day month well that's
a new one and yes
date of death living as I said this what
human beings do when they enter data so
you end up with you clean beta hopefully
it's clean as you can make it they'll be
surprises in there but we have 858
winners and the Saudi clean at this
point you want to explore
well if your motivation your you're
looking for a story's narratives you
know whatever you do it you you're
trying to summarize accounts inventory
if you're if you're trying to create a
weather visualization his stories this
is what people are interested their
house is just gonna clear just the noise
so how do you find stories here's a very
dull story the United States has won
more Nobel prizes in anyone else by a
big number
but using pandas we can easily create
little groups here I've just created
three groups representing the big
countries in Europe the big countries in
North America the big countries in Asia
just see there's historical trend and
what you can see is there is historical
trend is a huge huge increase in
American Nobel Prize winners post-war
when they start investing almost amounts
of money post Manhattan Project and
around about 1980s they passed the kind
of fairly pedestrian European countries
and kept on climbing so that's a story
that's a historical trend this is a huge
story look at this I mean a couple of
lines of pandas that the gender
disparity in Nobel Prizes is astonishing
there it is a couple of lines of and
this age of winners if you haven't won
it by about 105 you're probably not
gonna get a Nobel Prize friend at 60
yards you know so you can if you're an
academic and you have a kind in mind you
can work out your odds if you're a
famous Nobel Prize winner potentially
this is nice this is a couple of I'll
employ its Seaborn Siwon is a level
extension tutor and you see here they're
a remarkably long live Bunch Nobel Prize
winners they read leans their 80s 90s
far higher than national norm now of
course they are selected then our
elderly aged as a filter but it's still
pretty impressive so this gives you a
nice of this kitchen essentially is a
box plot with a distribution plot it's
very nice you can do interesting things
like looking at the correlation between
longevity and when they won their price
so here you can see has you probably
expenses epidemiologically they're
increasing in life expectancy and this
is a lot beautiful ALM plot this is one
of Seaborn's built in statistical plots
and it gives you it gives your
confidence interval as well which in
this case is pretty high this is a nice
one this is nice there's no the dice but
you this the data in this Nobel Prize
set had sometimes people being this is
Wikipedia so it's a bit of a free-form
sometimes people have been included by
both the nationality when they won the
prize and their original nationality
that's part of what the duplicates were
and of course if you
this suggests a correlation between
original original country and the
country where they won the prize this is
a diet I have moved
is there an interesting story in here
and of course if you can see there is
these that there and that there is when
you start looking hind it that's Jewish
scientists fleeing the Nazis during the
world during World War two very clever
soon to be Nobel Prize wins there is
another one mirrored which is part of
the austro-hungarian Empire collapsing
at the end of the Second World War a lot
of it then became quite anti-semitic a
lot of Jewish scientists and and writers
moved to America so this is this plot
here is then moving to America a lot of
Canadians moved to America as well I'm
sure a lot of Americans go the other way
anyway so there's a story there there's
those always all of us this is like
history writ large and it's just one
heat map so after you've done all that
you need to imagine your visualization
and just play around you you're you
don't make it too complicated too
difficult but at the same time you you
want allow people to discover some of
those stories that you've just explored
and yet what you should probably do is
suggest little kind of configurations
they might want to explore but they'll
prize you its geographical you can
expect a map if you want to list where
you can select the subsets that you've
been interested in and a bar charts and
all the standard heavy lifting with with
metrics that's useful and then to
humanize it in the bottom we take that
bio-data and we take the picture and we
just stick in there because one reason I
quite like the Nobel Prize day that says
lots of stories it's very human and it's
just about big enough to be kind of
interesting and trends then we want to
deliver the data so we've got the data
we need to deliver it to our
visualization flasks fantastically
powerful small succinct this is a manga
based restful api that's all the code
required to see here little settings
should be fairly self-explanatory
and here is the server that's it at this
point you are serving from a MongoDB
database straight to through flask
restfully Jason to your visualization
that is not very onerous I mean that's
pretty slot this is Python rain Friday
19 ah so there and yeah there's things
you there's lots of tailoring Jim dummy
NIMH is very well written this excuse me
other things to do but this is just a
very basic skeleton at which point you
got have to program in Java scripts like
I've been putting off this for a bit but
it's just generally syntax visualization
working jobs because almost all
declarative functional so you don't need
to worry about kind of the prototype
thing it's an interesting question but I
like JavaScript I get I enjoy it more
and more I find things missing in Python
when I come back to it and I didn't
think I would find myself saying that
but you can do things like this
first-class functional methods on the
right it's filter Map Reduce
I and because we're not most functions
you can really easily incorporate them I
mean Python that's really I didn't find
that quite clunky yeah and that's an
exciting result as well I just need to
understand them so the other thing is
maybe you don't know JavaScript of
smokes Python to speed so here we've got
respect from norm as about 60 times as
fast n-body 20 to 50 depends they're
doing weird things with v8 but
occasionally they basically get close to
see there's a lot of there's a lot of
bits to be working with so you can do
things which make me surprised at you
that the quite ambitious you can do them
in OpenGL - so we got a data delivery
system it's all come through from a
wikipedia page we've transformed it and
now we want to sense the visualization
so here's the visualization I wrote took
in the book of which the book will teach
you how to build this essentially now
let's see us to see a few stories so
here's one story that's a pretty big
story I think it's fair to say so those
dots the top barrels Nobel Prizes and
for women it looks if there's been an
improvement recently but let's filter by
category shall we physics this is one a
big interest of mine Maria got Maya
hands up here who they've heard of her
right well that's terrifying because
she's the only woman other than Mary
Curie he probably have heard of to win a
physics Nobel and she wanted the
theoretical work whereas Marie Curie
essentially wanted to doing incredibly
arduous dogsbody them I'm not saying she
just doctor Onishi doodle but he wasn't
theoretical so Mary go kamiya why not
more people not a hurt she's the only
the second woman to win a Nobel Prize
for Physics but she dropped out a couple
of couple of clicks to the van there's a
story for you which I said I was had the
daughter I want her to know about that
woman makes all categories what happens
if we if we measure by country size no
obviously America wins on the absolutes
but he's got 300 million people
Santa Lucia does well Derek Walcott West
Indies got population at 12 so Derek
will go he start dividing all right so
let's we can filter that out but let's
just go for physics just kind of
countries like Santa Lucia can't afford
a big physics budget you know even
theoretical physics they can't even
thought to give someone a pencil to do
the theoretical physics so here we go
you only hear from Holland well hey
right shadow pond Holland if you if you
normalize for capita not just Holland
but Denmark
basically the Scandinavian countries and
Switzerland are all bouncing way above
their way sorry
it'll happen you're not yet sixty right
you've got don't think window of
opportunity so I can prove that I have
numbers so there's another story let's
do one more story and the point I'm
trying to make is there are stories in
you I didn't I don't know what you're
interested in I can't you old-fashioned
editorializing for graphics and stuff
base you say I know exactly what you're
interested in I'm going to show it to
you well I don't I can suggest using
data is like this but I want you to find
your own stories you might be a stallion
that I'm not if you're estonian you're
pretty very interested in estonian
winners so let's just let's take all the
pro notes now let's look at one more
thing if this says a lot about the world
so this is the the prize for economics
almost every every prize has gone to an
american it says a lot about the
post-war economic consensus thank you
says all awaken ama sexually give him
what's going down but anyway have
nothing I think I just did there you go
economic she stitched up and it goes to
America would you wait we're at European
so we don't even well summers somehow
countries are trying to use that model
but that's strange isn't it all of it
all the Condors come for America it
looks like someone's been stitching up
people right this is the original does
it work yeah that's it this was the
original page so this is ELISA Nobel
Prize father I used grey P to turn this
as you see she won these links goes to a
human being goes to the photo on the bio
and I used to grapey together all that
didn't take long
turning to Jason and the idea was to
transform it into what we saw now what's
the what's the web dead load I mean how
much of that horrible icky HTML stuff do
you really need for that visualization
I'm just showing you well this is it
this is the skeleton for that it's got
the man it's got the bar chart that's
the skeleton and two guys that's less
Owen wrist and stuff I stuff to write in
the cutesy just to get shims between
that and see that's it and then you take
that backbone and you use JavaScript to
flesh it out and as I said that's just
programming it's what we do it's
empowering and d3 does the heavy lifting
it's thing I mentioned Heath relax it's
the best buy so by so far amount a
margin best visualization library I
think it's just in JavaScript a bird
certainly in JavaScript a lot of people
are you know doing professionally and
and talked to them and they are so via
they never gets that position where you
can't do something and most libraries
lock up after a while and d3 doesn't
because it's very flat we filled out so
summary jason is the big deal if you're
doing data and you plan to get on the
web then jason is really quite nice and
it's certainly what you want to be
working with python makes that trivial
- Josh people do work really well if you
get that a horrible web dev countdown
and you can't get down to us a nice
minim you're just programming and you
know you can think of the web page is a
canvas that you would program in place
and if you were doing WX or opt these
are exciting times the job strategy just
isn't very fast it's getting fast let's
go 100% device budget if I do a little
sketch in Java but the one I just showed
you I then just give some of the URL and
I've shared it with them that's a big
idea and they can look it on the mobile
yeah I can sit in the coffee house with
someone and they just go to that page on
their phone there and then that's a big
idea and I don't know it's I can get
blase but I you know I never talked with
a friend and they and just they just go
through what my way so this guy could
mine out did this amazing visualization
that you probably all seen in Napoleon's
disastrous Russian campaign and he
combined mortality rates with geography
you know what was then a completely
novel way he was trying to do
multi-dimensional data presentation a
pioneer getting beyond pie charts and I
think we now have the tools to get
beyond bar charts and to start just
doing things with our data and getting
into their sitting into the primary and
primary how many cortex in ways that
have not been this is a this is virgin
territory
it's exciting that's the other thing you
want to be here if you are interested in
data vis and that's it sorry I don't
want apologize I wasn't ashamed it
that's why I'm holding
it's alright so we've got ten minutes
for questions around all of this or will
she grab here Emily sitting on the table
this during lunch
so nobody microphones first of all same
is gone like what are some of the back
that I closed down thank you yeah thanks
that's actually brilliant that's I've
been looking for a tool like that for a
very long time so it's I'm glad I can
like I'm glad I've discovered it the
question I've got is when you launch a
query on your visualization page on the
web page does he actually query the
database or do you have to preload the
stuff in 2d 3d Twitter are you can do
bus so in the case that we've seen so
I've got like optimal were different
when I put on my website I don't have a
server so is it static Lee frozen so
that's static frozen but the generally
the model was was either flask one I
showed you so that's essentially if
you've got any chunk of data of any size
you're gonna want to be quizzing a
database but when you're prototyping
yeah I mean I've read somewhere last
week that the average web page average
wave poses like two three megabytes now
with all the gunk and jars for it so I
mean that that job specs Nobel Prize
data sets quite small so you could just
offer it but when you get to 10 Meg and
stuff then yes and that's true that's
easy to do so most of the Big Data
subsequently is going to go straight to
the restful server so you're quizzing
the [ __ ] database but yeah Eva's Eve is
a recent Python library that as you I
just showed you it's a few lines and it
turns your [ __ ] database into a restful
api couldn't be easier really couldn't
and you if you're bouncing your data off
[ __ ] you can be exploring in pandas
update your
and database and immediately have that
reflected on the web so it's all it's
very easy it's very easy to be sorry
scientific Skippy is a package where you
can actually do like I don't know SVM or
like advanced using cycads yeah
scikit-learn and you tried to use it
with that plug you know that data that
not the data say now is I'm trying to
keep it very there's a lot in the book
so that the book is already very kind of
full and I I'm trying to avoid
succulents fantastic I think that dates
is quite small so but I have used
scikit-learn yeah and I'm incredibly
impressed but nothing that I use
scikit-learn wrapped up with numpy
inside a flask and serve up recommender
systems and the like that way using very
similar approaches to what Karen's
covered it so you you're mentioning that
week we've we going away from the static
for the pixel base with a visualization
to something more interactive and you
were mentioning as well but with a small
data sense that you can you can just put
it into HTML and then it will just run
it will just be there as the datasets
grow you have the problem that you need
a more complicated stack of technology
which meetings in the end that there's a
lot of effort to keeping it alive so to
say and really so in the end your
visualization if it's not a static face
it's gonna be very short blue know about
there's probably three or four years
time so what it what kind of trends do
you see how are people are dressing this
problem at the moment if the data if the
visualization is important it will be
adapted and maintained if it's a one-off
it'll be a historical kind of then I
mean it will still work unlike almost
every other visualization though they're
done people just be able to go there but
yeah everything all dates and these
curation
and if you design it well the curation
is fairly easy if it's if it's an API
and it's a well-designed API if it's
restful
there's not many ways in which it can
change or be adapted so I think I think
certainly the problem of adding to your
data augmenting your data is it's quite
easy to so if you if you factor it in
beforehand there are the tools to hand
base I Karen if you use like ipython
notebook you can tell a story as you go
through you've got a narrative is there
anything in d3 or visualizations we can
guide people through the visualization
to help them out yeah there are I mean
there's a lot of people who said if it's
virgin territory so people have explored
this the work of the New York Times I
mean my bus stop was working at times
with various pretty cool plugins to
enable interactive storytelling they're
doing some great I mean just things like
page scrolling it's actually there's a
good way and a bad way to do it if you
want the data to change and my posture
created these three Redis very nice
library and a very nice blog post based
around the problem scrolling so people
add the main themes a lot this has been
driven by by some of the bigger
newspapers the New York Times have been
pioneering so LA Times Washington Post
they're getting into it and they're
starting to find that they need these
tools to hand and so they are coming out
but yeah the idea of telling I mean I
think I think the idea of having
narratives there that you suggest but
also having a narrative today you can't
into it and that's the nice that's the
perfect balance thank you hi great talks
thank you I would like to ask that there
is a data visualization and there is
statistics yeah and for example in data
visualization we can do some very cool
visualization but which can be garbage
for example if we plot some mean
variables on sample of ten people or
five people the confidence interval
would be very large and our
viewer doesn't understand it but he will
see only visualization what is the
balance between data visualization and
traditional statistics in order to do
some very very fancy things but with
meaning statistical meaning in them I
think this is a list of Education you
the reason why a lot of visualizations
are kind of just trivialized meaning
this infographic key is because people
don't aren't trained in very basic so
tell me that here statistics and their
brain goes off probably around this room
knows there are some basic statistical
tests you should apply it when your
dataset and I like scientists for
training so you fans get drummed into
you I think a lot of people yeah it's
it's a lot of people it's snake-oil and
it feels good my feeling is that you
should be true to your school so you
should try not to not to be yeah walk by
the dark side but the visualization can
do anything and then you should do
things properly and I think little
things to me like mean and median
average you know our culture's decided
to use mean average GDP which is insane
because Rupert Murdoch moves into your
local town something everyone's a
millionaire that's obviously crazy but
we decided to use that as opposed to
median average which is a really much
better one for most people it's much
closer so ready we've got missus
propaganda right this is where people
not educated I believe the only defender
sees education because if you're
educated they're going to look at these
infographics that don't include this
basic stuff and they're inoculated and
they'll still laugh at them and they'll
stone the people you made them and
they'll send them away to foreign
countries and stuff and you'll get back
to how things used to be
stocks a good
thanks Karen great presentation what are
your thoughts on bouquet of you have you
checked out okay
Bobby's lovely there's so many things
are lovely so when I started writing the
book I was going to do a chapter on
bouquet and I was gonna do a chapter on
various other things I like flatly but I
want to do it all open source in Korean
so and Bach is very impressive there
were few at the time the ecosystem was
so stable and it'll stay still stable
it's not stable yet but there were about
five or six competing smacks off lived
III and there was a sense that they
weren't gonna survive
baki a seems to have survived I like it
I like the fact the AIDS similar to t3
it's looking at kind of looking at the
fundamental core of drawing it used the
canvas doesn't use my probably things
like Bach cake it's a personal thing but
once once you've tasted the real drug
you never taste the real drug it's fine
because but once you taste it you can
never go back now I could look a book
your clothes and I'm very frustrated
because I can do these three you know I
know and I can kind of think of
something just do it and that's a good
time but you're crossing two languages
sorry you're with Booker you're in one
language right eventually you're gonna
have to debug on the browser this is the
other things are all kind of lies we
tell ourselves sorry it's like coffee
spirits and I mean cause repetition sees
JavaScript right they're all they're all
props and you just gotta come to terms
with the fact that debugging the browser
is lovely it's a very nice experience
much nicer than debugging pison
javascript is getting better and better
and you're gonna have to come to terms
with jealousy someday someone's gonna
write numpy in JavaScript or something
and then you'll be a canvas [ __ ] seven
and it will actually be a really nice
like please I wish point five things
gonna have some problems
because Giles was a lot faster I think
right now if the thing is to be friendly
because if you try not be friendly if
you don't make it easy to fight into
tween throughout the JavaScript fight
and having difficulties really the the
momentum the JavaScript she knows I
didn't mention noticed about the
elephant living room it's not data ready
yet
they're building those libraries they're
thoughtful in the main and there's a lot
of horrible api's that change every
Tuesday but they're doing it and they've
got the Pacific all the power but 60 to
100 times faster than Python at the
moment and pythons beeps and change very
much
so sabaki scare about the question
Bucky's lovely I haven't got him to talk
about it um but I I love the idea I
think that I still think once you've
tasted the real thing it's my question